this video is brought to you by
surfsharkvpn
what's up guys Michael here to talk
about the only place where it's
acceptable to wear gym shorts and eat
pizza for two weeks straight while being
guided through the works of Dostoevsky
by a PhD in Russian literature yeah
College a key aspect of the American
dream receiving a college education has
long been seen as critical to living a
good and prosperous life but
increasingly higher education comes with
crippling debt and fewer job
opportunities young adults today are
better educated than ever and
increasingly downwardly mobile but it
wasn't always destined to be this way so
how did the Great American college
experiment blow up in our faces
foreign
let's find out in this wisecrack deep
dive into higher education what went
wrong
okay before we keep going I want to tell
you about this video sponsor
surfsharkvpn search shark VPN keeps your
data secure everywhere you go on the
Internet thanks to their secure
protocols and uncrackable encryption now
something that I really like about using
surf shark is that it keeps my location
completely private which is a huge
Advantage when I'm buying stuff like
plane tickets because if a website knows
where I am they can gouge prices based
on what they think I can afford and we
don't want them to do that do we all I
have to do is connect my secure surf
shark VPN to other vpns around the world
until I track down the best price and
speaking of the world these connections
also make it easy to watch all the
content that hasn't been released in
your country I'm a sucker for a lot of
UK shows so with surf shark it's very
easy for me to access things that
otherwise I wouldn't be able to watch
now all of your favorite devices are
included with a single subscription so
your laptop Android Amazon Fire stick
PlayStation and more plus you can still
use your favorite apps like Chrome and
Firefox so get started by clicking the
link in the description and using the
promo code wisecrack when you do you'll
get surfsharkvpn for 83 off plus three
extra months for free so go to
surfshark.deals wisecrack or hit the
link in the description protect yourself
online and download surfsharkvpn today
and now back to the show so the modern
University is a lot like pizza and that
it started a long time ago in Italy and
then got taken to America where
initially only World War II veterans
wanted it but eventually it became a
rite of passage for every American
Teenager okay let me explain the first
modern University started in 1088 in
Bologna what made it modern is that it
was independent of the church and
granted degrees they had six areas of
study broken up into pairs of three
grammar rhetoric and logic basically the
humanities wing and geometry music and
astronomy their version of stem soon
after this in the 12th century the
University of Paris and Oxford were
established and it was Off to the Races
an important part of early European
universities was the recovery of
Aristotle a time during which most of
Aristotle's texts were translated into
lat the standard academic language of
the time this led to the emergence of
scholasticism a school of thought which
used Aristotelian categories as a
jumping off point for the study of the
humanities and the Sciences and which
was synthesized with Christian theology
by people like Thomas Aquinas and as
European universities expanded they
considered intellectual inquiry a part
of fully embracing one's humanity and
even developing one's spiritual self it
also engendered a style of study marked
by close readings of text led by
Scholars or teachers Reflections on
those texts and then discussions about
those texts basically an early version
of the lecture and seminar style of
teaching that still dominates today but
importantly these universities were not
places where people primarily trained
for careers but places where one carried
out humanistic courses of study and
philosophy theology language and natural
science and the first American
universities like Harvard Yale and
Princeton basically picked this up and
Rift on it the same universities that
would go on to count numerous
prestigious war criminals as alumni
hello Dick Cheney and George W bush for
much of America's history both pre and
post-revolution the University was a
Bastion of learning but typically Only
For Preparing People to be teachers or
members of the clergy and while these
universities weren't one-for-one copies
of Oxford they were still largely
working in a European model that
emphasized education in the humanities
and Natural Sciences basically they were
a few years off from offering coding
boot camps because these jobs were not
particularly well paid people pursuing
them were seen as doing so for the
benefit of their community so their
communities typically paid for their
education whether through Government
funding or donations Robert L Geiger
education historian explains that as a
result many early colleges including
Stanford and Baroque University charged
students nothing despite that they were
still mostly attended by the wealthy in
part because as 18th century Farm Boy it
was hard to convince your dad to let you
go off to study Aristotle and Mozart for
four years over the mid-19th century
colleges proliferated all over the
country usually founded by philanthropic
religious or special interest groups
Federal incentives to create colleges
starting 1862 with the moral land grant
act in which states were rewarded for
selling western land if it was used to
host College programs in agriculture
mechanical and Military Sciences Federal
funding continued to pour into higher
education for decades at the same time
changes caused by the Industrial
Revolution created a need for highly
trained managers and other professionals
this shifted College from something that
facilitated intellectual exploration and
training for service-oriented vocations
into a place that would help you achieve
professional success and this is about
where things still stood in the waning
years of World War II College was
basically the exclusive luxury of the
wealthy and Elite and in 1940 just 15
percent of people aged 18 to 21 were
enrolled but that was all about the
change and mostly to avoid pissing off
Veterans as chronicled by journalist
will bunch in his book after The Ivory
Tower Falls see after World War One
veterans frustrated at the minimal
benefits offered to them had lobbied for
more government support in the aftermath
of the Great Depression they took their
grievances to the street in a protest
March on Washington that turned bloody
after police responded shocking we know
not eager to run this one back and
approach coaching his fourth
presidential election Franklin Roosevelt
wanted to revive the excitement of the
New Deal thing is most of his ideas
relied on higher taxes on the wealthy
which weren't about to make it through
Congress but helping veterans that was
different because it could attract the
support of conservative allies eager to
support the troops even if it took the
Forum of housing educational or
unemployment benefits rather than Direct
Cash via the GI bill as Bunch writes
College benefits were an afterthought
and emerged from the Capitol Hill
negotiations only as somewhat of an
accident basically nobody seriously
thought that returning soldiers many of
whom came from working class families
and hadn't even finished high school
would be that interested in higher
education which remained heavily gate
kept by the wealthy Elite for their part
those like the University of Chicago's
president feared the GI bill would
transform colleges into quote hobo
jungles full of ignorant lazy vagabonds
if only it was around now to watch Rush
week at Arizona State or UC F anyway
promises to pay for veterans education
along with a stipend for their books and
living expenses didn't seem like a big
commitment at most like 1 million would
take advantage of the opportunity right
wrong by late 1946 veterans made up
nearly half of American undergraduates
and to everyone's surprise performed as
well as or better in class despite not
having any Rockefeller blood in their
veins blood that was probably inbred
anyways according to Bunch college
education started being treated as a new
National priority and a public good and
not just for World War II vets after
Roosevelt died President Truman
established a commission on higher
education which concluded that the
federal government should ensure free
education for all Americans through the
first two years of college and even
longer for lower income students there
were two sides to this proposal an
idealistic one and a military one
idealistically Commissioners believed
that a generalized liberal education
would nurture democracy and Foster a
more equal America at the same time time
universities were seen as a place where
the Cold War would be won in science and
technology classrooms and through
pentagon-funded research as dispersed by
the National Science Foundation which
was established in 1950. just a quick
note this was the beginning of a
marriage between the military and the
university that is oh so alive and well
to this day so if you feel like marriage
doesn't work just look at the military
industrial complex in the government and
have hope that you can find that too
despite the Truman commission's urging
no federal legislation followed
according to Bunch that's in large part
because southern congressmen feared
Federal involvement with campuses would
force them to desegregate so yeah you
can blame some of the reason for your
student loan debt on Southerners refusal
to give up segregation oh also they were
scared of all the Kami professors who
had fled Europe to teach in America
um they fled Europe because of the
Holocaust you know like cultural scholar
and theorist Theodore dorno and Albert
Einstein you know the guy who invented
gravity but even without legislation
college enrollment was skyrocketing as
was tuition from 1956 to 1970 enrollment
tripled while spending on college
education spiked six-fold but in 1957
things changed dramatically when Russia
won the first lap of the Space Race via
the satellite Sputnik by 1958 a spooked
Congress passed the National Defense
Education Act which both increased
research funding and offered something
new student loans this was a compromise
widespread students scholarships struck
conservatives as a bit socialist at a
time when being even a little Marx
curious could get you excommunicated
from society so student loans put more
of the onus on students future selves to
fund their own education because
education was an investment not a right
the idea of student loans came out of
free market Economist Milton Friedman's
human capital Theory which saw the human
being as a unit of investment investing
in college students was seen as a smart
thing to do the payoff was a
well-educated adult with a high chance
of Landing a good job I wonder how much
I'm worth as a unit of investment I
don't think much notably the
establishment of loans expressed a
growing strain of thought that education
was not going to be as FDR and the
Truman commission argued a matter of
public good but of personal
responsibility according to Bunch the
late 50s and early 60s were the Golden
Age of American college a time when
higher education seemed to deliver on
its offer of upward Mobility fostering
democracy and civil engagement and
furthering advancements in science and
technology of course the Golden Age was
anything but perfect colleges in the
South fought to maintain segregation and
when black students were admitted they
faced violent racism like the University
of Texas's first black law school
student admitted after he won a case in
the Supreme Court during his first
semester someone burnt a cross on campus
with the passing of President Lyndon
Johnson's Higher Education Act in 85
federally guaranteed student loans were
expanded for the middle class as were
scholarships for lower income students
expanding student loans was an Earnest
attempt to make College more widely
accessible while still palatable to
conservatives College was officially
mainstream a new rite of passage and a
new youth culture flourished thanks to
increased Leisure Time and the free
thinking inspired by the widespread
liberal arts Curriculum by the time baby
boomers had taken over campuses this
became the counterculture and activists
spearheaded radical movements about Free
Speech civil rights and women's rights
via groups like these students for a
Democratic Society this caused tension
from the get-go take the University of
California Berkeley where overt student
political activity had been banned as a
Vestige of McCarthyism it became the
site of the Free Speech protest
culminating in rallies that were met
with police brutality spurred on by
anti-vietnam War sentiment student
activism intensified ironically as
college students raged against the war
the the expanding University ecosystem
was being bankrolled by federal funding
for military focused stem research
College activism was met with a
conservative backlash embodied by
California governor Ronald Reagan who
tried and basically failed to end the
state's long-standing tradition of free
tuition though he did manage to
establish a different fiscal burden for
students via Sky High enrollment fees he
lobbied for public hearings on the
communism and sexual promiscuity he
believed was infiltrating UC campuses
which I mean if only importantly Reagan
argued that the liberal arts education
at the time was misguided and that
college should be about training
workforces not say expanding students
Minds this is so basically a complete
disconnect from the classical vision of
humanistic education the violence of the
1960s political movements culminated
with the Kent State massacre in which
national Guardsmen opened fire on
students protesting the Vietnam War
killing four known as the day the 60s
died these killings ignited Nash
National protest and outcry from an
older Middle America who believed
college students were delinquent in a
Gallup poll from the time a whopping 58
percent of Americans blamed the Kent
State students for their own deaths
while just 11 blamed the National Guard
who actually fired the bullets out of
their guns that they pointed at students
while their fingers were on the triggers
of the guns with the bullets that were
pointed at the students but what do I
know I've never been in the National
Guard over the course of the early 1970s
the conservative backlash to the
counterculture born on college campuses
which led to the election of Richard
Nixon wood according to Bunch changed
the American way of college and crush
the egalitarian dreams of the post-war
planners basically once College became
mainstream it created a lot of free
thinkers who looked at American society
and didn't like what they saw and this
pissed off a lot of powerful people this
backlash came down to of the fact that
college campuses have become a place
where ideologies that threatened the
capitalist machine could flourish but
money was about to get in the way of all
of that in 1970 the average American
student paid 585 tuition per year again
they paid for a whole year of college
585 dollars that's crazy either I
literally think there's textbooks that
cost almost that much now in the
comments let us know what your most
expensive textbook ever was that was
about to start changing and fast but the
reason was counter-intuitive let's flash
back a second to Johnson's creation of a
federally guaranteed student loan plan
in 1965. importantly Johnson had a big
problem his Great Society movement which
included Medicare Medicaid and aid for
elementary and secondary education had
drastically increased government
spending and thus the federal deficit a
big deficit hurts the government's
ability to borrow money at low interest
rates and because of Arcane budget rules
his student loan proposal posed a big
problem as Wall Street Journal reporter
Josh Mitchell explains if the government
originated 1 billion in student loans
spending increased by 1 billion this was
a mirage since the spike would be
temporary years later students monthly
payments would reduce the resulting
deficit but What mattered at the time
was the immediate budgetary hit how
however if someone else lent money to
the students it was basically off the
books as far as the treasury was
concerned so how do you make a ton of
money available for students to borrow
you turn to the banks there was
precedent for this after the Great
Depression Congress had created the
Federal housing Administration to ensure
or guarantee some mortgages made by
lenders that eliminated risk for banks
lending to potential home buyers the
federal government stepped in to
guarantee all student loans and thus
limit risks for investors they set
interest rates at six percent it only
took a few months for Johnson's plan to
encounter some trouble namely inflation
basically this made issuing loans and
thus earning interest less profitable by
1969 Congress had to raise interest
rates to 10 percent to keep Banks
willing to participate at the same time
colleges feared what would happen as the
Baby Boomers started aging out of higher
ed leaving schools with a smaller pool
of customers because their customers at
the school it's a service and you're
just customer as Mitchell writes Banks
needed more money colleges needed more
money students needed more money the
government's foray into student lending
was already a mess producing unintended
consequences so Johnson started a panel
headed by bureaucrat Alice rivlin to
figure out what to do there were two
options lend to colleges directly or
keep lending to students the panel
decided that lending the students
empowered them as consumers and
encouraged colleges to compete thus
hypothetically holding tuition in check
everybody wins or something but as Banks
started forcing interest rates up
rivlin's panel proposed a new plan
creating a non-profit federally overseen
agency that could loan to Banks who
could then loan to students following
this plan in 1972 Congress created the
student loan marketing Association AKA
Sallie Mae they empowered Sallie Mae to
borrow money almost as cheaply as the
federal government and provided
guaranteed loans to Banks now assumed no
risk Sallie Mae also bought back loans
previously paid out by Banks the system
was crazy convoluted as Mitchell writes
Sallie Mae was part of a circuitous
route between lender and borrower to
recap the treasury Department gave money
to the Federal Financing bank which lent
to Sallie Mae which provided cash to
Banks which lent to students who paid
schools this sounds like gabbadygook
rest assured not even the people making
these laws totally understood what was
going on as Senator Jennings Randolph
said in a 1981 hearing if most members
of Congress were asked what they thought
of Sally May they would respond with a
question who is she the tldr is that the
more money students borrowed the more
money Sally May made and it would become
highly profitable earning huge amounts
through fees interest and commissions
off of billions of dollars of loans
because of their low borrowing cost they
made a return of 3.5 percent on student
loans average returns over the past 50
years haven't exceeded 1.6 percent
meanwhile Banks were free to lend money
with Nary a concern for the borrower's
ability to repay because they were
assured payment from the federal
government presented with a wider Market
of students floating in a sea of loan
money colleges did what any industry
would do they raised prizes tuition
started Rising every year while
for-profit universities sprang up to
capitalize on the new College industrial
complex and it paid off as Mitchell
writes Sallie Mae's profits Rose
defaults to Rose driving up taxpayer
costs the banking industry profited as
its Schools students and taxpayers
incurred all the cost he calls this the
quintessential form of crony capitalism
it privatized profits and socialized
losses that is to say when things went
well a few people made a bunch of money
when things went badly the public lost a
ton of money perhaps unsurprisingly
around the same time the purpose of
college began to conform more to
Reagan's Vision students taking out
increasingly substantial loans were less
focused on obtaining a generalized
liberal arts education and more focused
on ensuring they picked a discipline
that would get them a well-paying job so
that they could pay off their loans
numbers of business majors skyrocketed
and Humanities Majors plummeted across
the board rip to Aristotle and
Shakespeare this is reflected in what
students said they value about their
college education in 1970 70 percent of
students called it very important or
essential to develop a meaningful
philosophy of life in their education
forty percent prioritized using it to
make more money by the mid 80s aka the
American Psycho era these stats had
flipped while the whole rationale for
Lending to students instead of colleges
was to create a more competitive market
the opposite kind of happened as
Mitchell explains higher tuition made a
school more attractive to families not
less This was later dubbed the shivas
Regal effect for a high-end whiskey
College seems to be a good that people
are more likely to buy if it's more
expensive as Roger L Geiger explains
starting in the 80s and 90s top
institutions didn't compete by keeping
prices reasonable instead they competed
by justifying high prices via their
Prestige maintained by marketing
Recruitment and branding along with that
a rising phenomenon of luxury perks on
campuses would emerge eventually ranging
from glitzy condominium style living to
Gourmet Food to recreational centers
with rock climbing walls and lazy Rivers
author and journalist Ron Lieber calls
this the beginning of an amenities arms
race see the university can't stay out
of arms races any type of arms race it
just wants to be involved but the
absolute Insanity of the student loan
crisis and the number of people
profiting off of it was about to go into
overdrive by 1990 Sallie Mae had about
40 billion dollars in assets among them
half of American student debt but there
was more money to be made Sally May
along with its lobbyist convinced
Congress to let it become a for-profit
publicly traded Corporation remember
that it could borrow at insanely low
government level rates and you'll get
why Investments poured in from around
the world Sally May aggressively
expanded infiltrating every aspect of
the student loan industry stifling
competition and offering private loans
with interest rates as high as 28
percent as of 2007 the top two
Executives had made more than half a
billion dollars eventually its main
initial Congressional backer Bill Ford
would describe Sallie Mae point blank as
a money laundering operation guess they
should have given Sally a more Italian
sounding last name it's okay you're
still we're still allowed to make jokes
about Italian so if anyone got offended
you're wrong I'm allowed to I have an
Italian grandpa so it's okay all the
while the cost of college was soaring
higher and higher because it could
Sallie Mae used its lobbying power to
convince Congress to strip away consumer
protections on student loans very
importantly this included the rules
around student loan bankruptcy initially
back in 1976 Congress deemed student
loans non-dischargeable in the case of
bankruptcy but only for five years this
number was extended to seven and
eventually abolished altogether to this
day student loans are the only kind of
loan in American history to be
non-dischargeable I declare
bankruptcy
Sallie Mae and the banks weren't the
only ones benefiting from rising student
loans as complaints about Sallie Mae
festered Clinton signed a federal
government Direct Loan program into law
this eliminated Sallie Mae as the
middleman as the government began
accumulating loans it was able to use
future repayments to balance its books
it essentially became what Bunch calls a
form of deficit control meanwhile just
as College was being rendered
unaffordable for all but a lucky few and
creating a future of ballooning debt for
the many a college education was
becoming more essential to job security
than ever before and the American
government the banks and Sallie Mae were
all too eager to profit off that
desperation it stands to reason that as
colleges became more expensive than ever
before the people in charge sought to
run them in the most lucrative way
possible like businesses everyone who
teaches in our department has experience
in the corporate environment as well
it's not just a textbook each one of us
has had positions as president of
Corporations senior VPS vice presidents
we breathe reality and that's a huge
shift from how we used to view the
university one seen as a source of
public good a place to train future
teachers and clergy to help their
communities they've increasingly become
corporations in their own right as Henry
Giroud writes within the wider
socio-political environment corporate
power and interest are all too willing
to Define higher education as a business
venture consumers as investors and the
faculty as a cheap source of Labor left
to the logic of the market education is
something that consumers and investors
now purchase for the best price deal and
profit he describes how this shift
affects everyone involved University
presidents become CEOs faculty become
entrepreneurs and students become mere
consumers from the top down universities
are governed by market-like principles
based on metrics control and display of
performance and what's called an output
of fundamentalism the session with
quantifiable data like productivity
performance and the ability to bring in
grant money has supplanted any value of
serious scholarly Pursuit and I got to
see this firsthand the last University I
taught at full time evaluated our
program on the basis of our students
ability to get full-time careers a year
from graduating jobs like working at a
Bookshop or a coffee shop didn't count
so they evaluated our ability to teach
philosophy and teach students how to
think philosophically on their success
on the open job market and then we would
get less money for the program on the
basis of that it was great as scholar
David rasowski points out running a
college like a business full stop risks
sacrificing some of the most
foundational elements of a broad-based
education intellectual Pursuit inquiry
discourse transmission and discovery of
knowledge focusing only on those fields
that generate Revenue maximize product
I.E graduates value and create wealth
running schools like businesses
inherently affects both what's being
taught and how they're being taught in
this way universities are being reduced
to what sociologist Peter siebold calls
a corporate services station where the
values and topics being taught are
functionally for sale to the highest
bidder note that this is largely
specific to science and Business Schools
where corporate interests mostly lie
rather than the humanities because the
humanities struggle to get private
funding in the first place and their
departments often simply shrink or shut
down altogether I could not tell you how
many philosophy departments have shut
down since I started grad school it
sucks for example with stem subjects
priority is given to topics that will
bring in heavy investments from biotech
companies big Pharma and the military
researchers are encouraged to pursue
topics that will yield Hefty funding
rather than those of most scientific
value remember how a huge amount of
early Government funding for
universities was intended for military
research that's only in 10 identified in
recent decades as Jerrell argues many
universities have become irrevocably
enmeshed in the military-industrial
complex for instance MIT gets 75 percent
of funding for its robotics Department
from the Department of Defense as gero
writes military research on campuses has
dangerous implications for the academy
and for the larger social order it
produces lethal weapons subverts the
peaceful use of scientific knowledge
fuels an arms race debases the talents
of the faculty and students take for
instance the time in 2006 when Scholars
from the American anthropological
Association found out that some of their
colleagues work was adapted by the U.S
armed services to develop interrogation
tactics at Abu ghraib for those of you
who are fortunately young enough to have
missed this exceedingly disturbing
moment in the war on terror that's the
Iraq War era prison where the Army and
CIA committed especially heinous acts of
torture abuse and murder if you want
Hollywood's an exact intro to this era
check out zero Arc 30 and if you want to
get into the psychology of the people
that did the torture check out the card
counter starring Moon Knight back when
President Dwight D Eisenhower famously
warned about the military industrial
complex he considered also calling it
the military industrial academic complex
though he removed the latter phrase from
his speech he still noted that a
government contract becomes virtually a
substitute for intellectual curiosity
but if you can't convince the Pentagon
to throw you a few pennies there's
always hope that some eccentric
billionaires might help Florida State
University made an agreement in which
influential business magnates the Koch
brothers pledged 1.5 million dollars in
exchange for being allowed to screen and
sign off on any Economic Department
faculty hires similarly BB T Corporation
a financial Holdings company gifted
Marshall University's business school
one million dollars under the
stipulation that Ein rand's objectivist
novel Atlas Shrug be taught in the
business school they had to teach Iran's
book in the business school arguably
this has consequences as gero writes
increasingly universities are losing
their power not only to produce critical
and civically engaged students but also
to offer the type of education that
enables them to refute the neoliberal
utopian notion that paradise amounts to
a world of veracity and avarice without
restrictions governed by a financial
Elite to exercise Authority without
accountability or challenge once places
for Collective growth and engagement
with Big Ideas universities are
increasingly becoming places where
people go to acquire skills for personal
enrichment Giro argues that this
produces robots technocrats and
compliant workers what's more it refutes
the idea of general education as a means
of furthering democracy and public
engagement as scholar Stewart Jane
Murray explains this logic co-ops and
eviscerates the language of the common
good essentially if College were once
about engaging people in their broader
communities increasingly they're about
benefiting the community of one the
laser focus on what the market
supposedly wants and what makes for a
profitable return on investment in
education is only intensified by the
for-profit university industry
for-profit universities have long
existed on a small scale they were among
the first to implement correspondence
education the early version of online
learning popular in the 1920s where
students were educated by mail this is
one of many tactics they use to appeal
to non-traditional students like high
school dropouts still they made up a
very small segment of the college
ecosystem for most of American history
in the early 1970s just 0.2 percent of
higher education students went to
for-profit schools but then came the
University of Phoenix originally started
by John Sperling formerly a college
professor and Union activist the
University of Phoenix sought to make
education more available to working
adults within a decade it had six
thousand students it took its education
online in 1989 yes 1989 and its parent
company went public in 1994. it proved
that for-profit schools which had
largely been small trade schools could
be highly highly profitable and many of
those small schools similarly went
public for-profit colleges have a pretty
good deal they earn approximately 88
percent of their revenue from Federal
loans that's because the government has
a rule that they can't earn more than 90
percent of the revenue from those loans
this is supposedly how the government
ensures that only super high quality
for-profit schools Will Survive ninety
percent that's how the insurance super
that's crazy that's crazy government
you're crazy for this one USA but here's
the catch a large amount of the other 12
percent according to sociologist tressy
McMillan cottam comes from veterans
benefits essentially the government is
providing nearly all the funding for
for-profit colleges arguably another
huge turning point for for-profit school
schools came in 2002 with a simple
Department of Education memo that
indicated that for-profit colleges would
not be punished for compensating
recruiters based on how many students
they enrolled enrollment subsequently
soared growing 75 percent from 2006 to
2010 but something more Sinister was
happening there was spooky ghosts at the
colleges no that wasn't it it's
encapsulated by one example back in 2004
the University of Phoenix started a
two-year associate's degree program and
all was fine and dandy until a 2008
investigation by the U.S Senate's health
education labor and pensions committee
found that 66 percent of students
enrolled in the associates program had
dropped out within the first year chair
of the committee Senator Tom Harkin
credits this to for-profit schools
recruitment methods he explains what
drives the profits is how many students
they enroll the school gets the money
they pay their shareholders they pay
their school administrators and the
student drops out and has this debt
hanging over his or her head for the
rest of their life my debt is always
hanging here but we just CGI it out
because we have that technology this is
borne out by the way for-profit schools
spend their money cottam argues that if
budgets are moral documents you can make
your own judgments about how for-profit
colleges make theirs she reports that at
some of these institutions
22.4 percent of Revenue is spent on
marketing while 17.7 percent is spent on
instruction and the marketing tactics
have been pretty brutal back in 2011
Kaplan University documents obtained by
the Senate told recruiters to keep
digging until you uncover their pain
fears and dreams and to get to their
emotions and you will create the urgency
this is like advice for how to be a good
Freddy Krueger as well similar documents
from ITT Technical Institute suggested
recruiters poke the pain of it and
remind them who else is depending on
them and their commitment to a better
future future this is even more Sinister
when you consider who for-profit schools
are targeting low-income and minority
students an alarming 30 percent of
students who are single mothers attend
for-profit schools promising a brighter
future these schools have capitalized on
the gospel of Education that pervades
the American psyche
so now I've got to see which college is
right for me as Bunch writes in many
cases their aggressive pitch vastly
oversold the value of their diplomas in
the job market and a light of the fact
that courses were typically taught by
Harry underpaid adjuncts there have been
attempts to rein in for-profit schools
like when the Obama Administration added
a gainful employment rule wherein if not
enough students earned enough to pay
back their debt the schools would be cut
off from Federal loans but these
institutions continue to flourish note
that in 2021 the federal government
canceled 6 billion dollars in loans from
these institutions after concluding an a
class-action lawsuit that they were to
use the legal jargon basically scam
factories the bottom line about
for-profit schools is this they're
typically 30 to 40 percent more
expensive than traditional universities
and have a six-year graduation rate of
29 that's less than half the rate of
traditional universities this all
suggests that when education becomes a
matter of profit over education a lot of
vulnerable people lose out but there is
more to the snowballing College Fiasco
as non-profit and for-profit schools
increasingly ask for more money from
their students they're also increasingly
giving less money to arguably their most
important employees instructors
especially adjuncts who have little in
the way of job security or wages but
lots in the way of of toilet paper that
they steal from the University because
they can't afford it at home that's a
real thing I've done before now when I
was an Adjunct professor which I was on
and off for almost 10 years I would
teach at a rate between around 2500 and
four thousand dollars per a three hour
course per semester so let's say a
semester is 15 weeks that works out to
166 to 266 dollars a week three hour
class that met three times a week that
is 55 to 88 dollars per hour in the
class doesn't factor in time I spent
also office hours for time spent grading
which could be up to 10 to 15 hours per
class
students then means that those hours
plus the three hours of teaching this
doesn't factor in having to commute to
multiple campuses throughout the week of
course this all happened without getting
any type of benefit which is why I
didn't go to the doctor for five years
once that's a real thing if you're lucky
enough to get four classes this looks
like 20 to 32k a year again without
benefits and well I didn't work at any
school that offered Healthcare or
anything many universities like the
University of California system have
adjunct unions which have recently
ensured benefits which is really great
but most don't do that now many of the
schools I taught at had students paying
upwards of fifty thousand dollars a year
in tuition so think about all that money
coming in and the small amount going out
to the Educators and my experience is
not unique increasingly universities and
colleges of all Stripes not just for
profits are relying on underpaid adjunct
instructors while back in 1969 80
percent of Faculty were tenure or tenure
tracked that number dropped to just 27
percent by 2016. this means a growing
number of professors are living on
poverty wages while working in Secure
jobs it's hard to imagine producing
rigorous scholarship or even being an
Effective Teacher when you're worried
about affording groceries and this is
all while administrators regularly make
well into the six figures with Chief
Athletics administrators making on
average a hundred and five thousand
dollars a year or the amount that an
adjunct professor would make if they
taught around 35 courses in a year
because why pay professors to teach when
you can pay Duke's basketball coach
Coach K 12.5 million to scream in your
face to be clear I just told you that a
college basketball coach made 12.5
million dollars in one year at a
university where in 2017 adjunct faculty
were fighting for a living wage after
all sports have become yet another vital
way the universities turn education into
a money-making Enterprise Sports earn
universities billions of dollars 19
billion from the NCAA alone in 2018. and
this is all while the student athletes
at the heart of the industry make
nothing and up until recently didn't
even have the right to use their name
and image for endorsement deals of their
own as jerus summarizes too many
universities are now beholden to Big
Business big Sports and big military
contracts if you were waiting for us to
add and to Big students
don't hold your breath that's no that's
not it you know that's not it you've
gotten to this point in the video you
know that that's not it and this all
makes it feel like the actual education
part of the university is more of an
afterthought or at worst a necessary
evil of the new business forward model
of higher education so where does that
leave us today well it's no surprise
that Millennials and genziers who
enrolled after them are still battling
the vast majority of the country's 1.7
trillion dollars in student loan debt
and according to the Department of
Education about 116 billion dollars of
that total is just from interest and
thus we have a self-fulfilling prophecy
in our hands if you don't get a degree
in a field that's seen as profitable
you're destined to live on the brink of
personal economic disaster but you're
more likely to join the 74 percent of
gen Z and 68 of Millennials who put off
major life decisions due to their
student debt like buying a house having
kids or deciding between the pad thai or
the pad you this economic anxiety has a
direct influence on what people study
since the 2008 financial crisis for
example English departments across the
country have lost about 20 percent of
their Majors as students favor stem
Fields instead history Department
enrollment is down 45 percent and I'm
pretty sure philosophy departments have
about like 18 months left at best but
journalist Adam Kirsch argues that we're
missing out when we equate our degree to
our career he writes much of what
students of the humanities learn may not
be directly applicable to their lives or
careers very few of us need to know how
to identify a school of painting or
interpret a poem but a humanistic
education is supposed to teach us how to
read critically and think independently
skills that are crucial to democratic
citizenship but the issue isn't that
Humanities degrees are suffering because
they have poor job prospects according
to Benjamin Schmidt instead students are
fleeing Humanities in related fields
specifically because they think they
have poor job prospects while majors in
business and science make a bit more
than Humanities Majors the difference is
way more slight than what we are taught
to believe I.E you can still go out to
dinner with your buddy who went to
business school you'll just order a beer
and a burger while she orders two
martinis and the beef tartare in other
words the idea that your major
determines your income is more a matter
of perception than a matter of reality
but this perception matters saddling
students with loans increases the
pressure they feel to get high paying
jobs potentially swaying them away from
the kinds of egregiously underpaid
professions they might have originally
sought out like education social work or
being a public defender at the same time
education is as valorized as ever and
what cotton calls the education gospel
she writes the gospel is critical to
higher education shift to its vocational
premise that is the idea that higher
education is a moral good she argues
that because of this gospel we
increasingly demand more personal
Sacrifice from those who would pursue
higher education more loans fewer grants
more choices fewer practical options
more possibilities more risk of failing
to attain any of them we justify that
Demand by pointing to the significant
return in higher wages that those with
higher education credentials enjoy in
other words college is more expensive
than ever and it's harder to secure a
solid career than ever and yet we
continue to elevate the importance of an
egregiously expensive education to the
point where students are incurring a
lifetime's worth of debt all under the
belief that a degree is a necessary
price of admission for a good life so if
the university has really devolved into
a system in which basketball is valued
more than intellectual curiosity and in
which the only people not financially
screwed over are the administrators and
maybe it's Thousand-Year run is doomed
as Stuart Holland said the university is
a critical institution or it is nothing
and as it seems to become less critical
it also seems to be becoming more well
nothing in America politicians of all
Stripes have been proposing Solutions
but short of some limited student loan
forgiveness which we totally welcome but
frankly find underwhelming large-scale
change doesn't seem to be coming anytime
soon and the problem is so large scale
and multifaceted that it's hard to even
imagine what a quick fix would look like
it's infuriating and arguably specific
across Europe many college students are
not burdened by the same price tags that
their American counterparts face in
large part due to higher taxes overall
though even many European countries are
sadly becoming more American in their
approaches to higher education but
notwithstanding a broad shift in the way
our society thinks about the collective
burden of educating our citizens the
college problem sadly just doesn't feel
very fixable which isn't the funnest
place to land after watching a 45 minute
video but hey imagine how we feel after
researching writing and filming it but
what do you guys think is the American
college system past the point of saving
or is there a future where we rethink
our societal attitudes about the purpose
of Education let us know what you think
in the comments thanks as always to our
patrons for all your support and if you
feel like paying five to ten dollars a
month in tuition fees to wisecrack you
check out our patreon page if you
haven't yet we'll have a link in the
description like this video as if our
10-year review depends on it because
honestly it kinda does and as always
thank you so much for watching later
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
it is weird that like it's an online
university it's not really in a place
they could have chosen any [ __ ] you know
what I mean City like and that's you
sound prestigious with Phoenix